مشاهدينا نلتقي ان الى القاهره لمتابعه
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك لوزير
الخارجيه مصر وامريكا سامح شكري
[موسيقى]
ونحن نثمن علاقات الصداقه بين بلدينا
ونحرص على تعزيز ثلث العلاقه على اساس
الاحترام المتبادل والمصالح المشتركه
خلال مباحثتنا عكست بجلاء التقارب الواسع
في مصالحنا الاستراتيجيه
الخبير في رؤيه في رؤانا تجاه العديد من
القضايا كما اظهرت ايضا وجود امكانيات
هائله لتطوير شركاتنا
حلقات قدر التوافق الخائن في ما بين رؤى
البلدين سواء في مجال تطوير العلاقات بين
الاستراتيجيه فيما بيننا او فيما يتعلق
بتناول القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه نحن
نعول كثيرا على
التعاون من مشترك بين مصر والولايات
المتحده في اطار التحقيق الاستقرار
بالمنطقه الشرق الاوسط في دفع الجهود
التنمويه في العمل على تحقيق الاستقرار
وفقا للمبادئ الشرعيه الدوليه ووفقا
للمصالح المشتركه التي نعمل على تعزيزها
ولا تزال منطقه الشرق الاوسط طبعا
واحتلت قدر كبير سواء من محاسبات معالي
الوزير مع فخامه الرئيس او فيما يتعلق
بمحاسنا الموسعه فالقضيه الفلسطينيه كانت
حاضره بقوه خلال هذه المباحثات واهميه
لتحقيق الاستقرار لمنع اي نوع من التصعيد
وايجاد الاطار السياسي الملائم
للتوسل الى حل دائم وشامل وعادل القضيه
الفلسطينيه على اساس مبدا حل الدولتين
تاكيد انه همم تطورات الاخيره هي تطورات
مؤسفه همم نعمل على احتوائها وهمم والتوسل
الى همم اعاده التهدئه واعاده العمل على
همم مراعاه مصالح كل الاطراف وايضا
استقرار همم المنتخب همم
فبحثنا خلال همم لقاء انا ايضا ما يتعلق
بقضيه سد النهضه واهميه استمرار العمل
المشترك
للحفاظ على مصالح كافه الاطراف الثلاثه
همم وبما يحافظ على هذه المصالح وفقا
لقواعد القانون الدولي
والحقوق المشروعه في الحفاظ على الموارد
المائيه والامن المائي المصري همم ايضا
قنوات ليبيا والسودان
وهمم اهميه العمل المشترك
بمواجهه كل التحديات همم التي نعمل سويا
على همم تغلب عليها بالتاكيد انه همم
مواجهه الارهاب مواجهه التطرف من ضمن
الاولويات ال- همم الرئيسيه همم نعمل سويا
من اجل عقد اللجنه الاقتصاديه همم
المشتركه خلال هذا العام همم بمناسبه همم
التفاعل بمئويه العلاقات وهذا همم يزداد
اهميه في ضوء الاجواء الاقتصاديه الراهنه
والضغوط التي لا مصر منفرده ولكن تواجه
كثير من الدول الناميه في العالم ونتطلع
بان يكون هناك فرصه للمزيد من الاستثمارات
الامريكيه والعمل المشترك لمواجهه هذه
التحديات والتغلب على هذه الصعوبات برحب
معالي الوزير مره اخرى ودائما سعيد
لقاءاتنا اعتبره وصديق واا
نظير دائما كانت لقاءتنا مثمره وبتعمل في
اطار خدمه مصالح المشتركه البلديه سوف
نستمر على اتصال الوثير خلال الفتره
القادمه من اجل تحقيق مصالحنا المشتركه
النبي
اشكرك اشكرك على حسن الضيافه واشكرك ايضا
على الصداقه وشراكه التي امتدت على مدى
اعوامه وكما قلت فقد ربطنا علاقه قديمه
جدا
عندما كان الوزير سفيرا لمصر في واشنطن
وكانت بيننا علاقه جيده منذ ذلك الحين كما
اود ان اعرب عن بالبالغ تقديري
للرئيس السيسي الذي التقيت به ليله
عدد من المسائل التقينا عده مرات خلال
الاشهر والسنوات الماضيه واخرا في القمه
في همم مصر
وفي واشنطن وفيق القاهره
اللقاءات المتواصله تعكس همم
تقدير الشركه الاستراتيجيه بين بلدينا
واهميه هذه العلاقه للمنطقه ولا العالم
الولايات المتحده ومصر
ملتزمان بتعليقه هذه العلاقه والاولويات
في هذه العلاقه هي الب على المسائل
الاقتصاديه التي تنعكس ايجابا همم على
الطرفين
والاستثمارات في البناء التحتيه ونحن ندعم
600 مليون دولار قيمه مشروعه همم من
الكوابل يربط سنغافوره بفرنسا ومصر لتقديم
خدمات الاتصال همم سريع وكذلك همم
امكانيات الطاقه
الشمسيه والطاقه الهواء همم في مصر وهناك
همم تنافس في اسواق همم الطاقه المتجدده
وكما اشار الوزير هناك
بناء على مزيد من التعاون في المسائل
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه وفي خدمنا هذا كله
هو حتى وصل الى نتائج حقيقه
عمل وتحسين المعيشه ومستقبل افضل وهمم
ايضا تحدثنا عن الازمه الازمه المناخ وهي
فرصه لايجاد فرص عمل
للشعوبنا وهناك
مساله
القياده في همم كاب 27
[موسيقى]
وتحدثنا عن 50 مليون دولار من
مساعدات لحمايه همم
الشعب المرجانيه في البحر الاحمر
هي اا تحبي كل الاطراف اللي توفر المياه
واا
لمصر ودول الجوار السودان واثيوبيا كل هذه
الرسائل الصعبه شاهدنا فيها كثير من
المرونه
والتسامح من كل الاطراف ونقدر
هذه المسائل الوجديه همم للمصلحه المصريه
تقوم بهذا الدور وقد يكون هذا اكثر
الان وفي قمه همم
كان هناك دور مهم جدا للتحدث
قبل اسابيع همم فقط الحكومه المصريه
الامريكيه والبحرين والامارات ابو ظبي
نشكر مجموعه عمل
الصحه
وايضا هذا كان واسرائيل ايضا كل هذه
المسائل همم
تخفيف التوتر اا بين الفلسطينيين واسرائيل
وكذلك
التوتر الذي
تصاعد مؤخرا وكما نشهد الان
جديده بحثنا كيف نعمل معا لتقليل التوتر
مهمه جدا في
معالجه الوضع في ليبيا وعقد الانتخابات
هذا العام هو المسار الوحيد القابل للحياه
اختيار قياداتهم
وكانت هناك خطوه مهمه تمت من خلال مصر في
هذا الاتجاه والان نعمل مع المبعوث الخاص
للامم المتحده
همم التوصل الى هذه الانتخابات بشكل سريع
وايضا تحدثنا عن السودان
وانتقال السوداني الى الديمقراطيه وتشكيل
حكومه تلبي مطالب الشعب والعداله والامن
سياتي مع هذا وبالتالي سينعكس باقتصاد
الافضل للشعر
والمنتقابل وبالتالي هذه مسائل كانت على
قمه جدول امانينا وكذلك مع حوارتنا مع كل
الدول الولايات المتحده ترحب بالخطوات
التي تقوم بها مصر في حمايه حريه الاديان
وتمكين المراه
واقامه الحوار الوطني
واطلاق صراحه همم
المعتقلين
والنحتوا الحكومه المصريه
بتبقى اعتقال وكذلك حمايه ال صحفيين
والمدافعين عن حقوق الانسان كي تمكن كل
المصريين من العيش والتحدث والتعبير عن
الراي دون خوفا همم
تحسين وضع حقوق الانسان سيعزز علاقاتنا
الثنائيه فهذا مهم واولويه الكونجرس
بحزبيه ولهذا انا اعرف ان الرئيس يتابع
هذه الخطوات
تحدثنا عن الحرب
الروسيه البشعه على اوكرانيا وهذا همم
الغزو همم للضم اراد اوكرانيات
نحن ندعم
المبادئ المهمه التي يلتزم بها بلدينا في
ميثاق الامم المتحده وبالتالي ان تحترم
سياده الاراضي الاخرانيه
هذه المبادئ تحترمها كل الدول هذه الحرب
الروسيه
تنعكس ايضا على الشعب المصري فا مصر اكبر
مستورد
القمح في العالم من روسيا واوكرانيا
وعملنا لتقليل الضرر الذي نتج عن هذه
الحرب بدعم
قدرات مصر لانتاج همم غذائها وكذلك 50
مليار دولار
توجه لقطاع زراعه وكذلك مبالغ اضافيه
بتجاوز هذه المساله مساله النقص نقص
الحبوب العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
سجلنا 100 عام من العلاقات الثنائيه ونحن
نفخر بهذا التاريخ المشترك وهو ايضا في
نهايه الامر مستقبل مشترك وهذا جزء من
نقاشنا اليوم وفي كل يوم يوم امس التقيت
ببعض القيادات الشابه التي ترسم
المستقبل في كل مجال من اعماله وطب
وتكنولوجيا
وطاقتهم ورؤيتهم همم وثيقتهم بان المستقبل
مستقبل مصر ومستقبل علاقاتنا همم مشرق
وقوي
ينقلنا الى الامام وفي هذا اشكر لكم وزير
اييي
استاذه منى سالم
من قناه الاخباريه دينا سالم
طبعا العلاقه المصريه الامريكيه علاقه
استراتيجيه وممتده على مدى عقود طويله
الازمه الاقتصاديه التي يشهدها العالم
حاليا هي ازمه حد وتاثرت مصر بها في عده
مناحيل لكن هناك شعور لدى كثير من
المصريين بان مستوى الدعم الامريكي همم في
المجال الاقتصاديه لا يرقى الى همم مستوى
العلاقات وبما ان الولايات المتحده هي
الدوله الاكبر اقتصاديا رمانه الميزان في
المنطقه هل استشعرته خلال الاجتماعات همم
اليوم لان هناك همم اي تغير سنشهده في حجم
وطبيعه الدعم طبعا سياده الوزير الشارع
الى بعض همم
المشروعات التي ربما ستنف في مجال الطاقه
وايه اتحاد تمويليه اخرى همم لو تلخص لنا
ما تم الاتفاق عليه شكرا
الامريكيه في شقها الاقتصادي
وبالحقناه على ماذا
اربع عقود الماضيه من تطور في هذا المجال
همم
معونه الاقتصاديه اللي كانت يتم توفيرها
وال التي تم تخفيضها همم اتصال همم
احتياجات الخاصه بالولايات المتحده همم
واستجابه مصر لذلك ولكن دائما نحن نتطلع
الى مزيد من التعاون والاسلام من قبل
الولايات المتحده لما لديها من قدره من
الكليه اعلامها وهمم وامكانيات تاكيد ان
المشروعات التي ذكرها همم معالي الوزير
المشروعات مهمه همم ولكن هي مشروعات في
همم محدد بطاقه فني همم لكن الازمه
بالواجهها ودول الناميه كثيره همم في
الوقت الراهن همم تضخم همم
في الامن الغذائي في امن الطاقه اارتفاع
الاسعار كلها تقتدي مزيد من التعاون في
اطار العلاقه الاستراتيجيه ومزيد من
القدرات الامريكيه سواء من خلال العمل مع
مؤسسات التمويل الدوليه او من خلال
العلاقه الثنائيه همم
استشعارت من الوزير لينكن تقدير وتفهم
لهذه الضغوط الاقتصاديه
ورغبه في الاسهال في اا رفع هذه الضغوط
همم لا ما لان يكون الاجتماعات القادمه
للجنه ال- الاغتصاب
اطار والياف يكون لها تاثيرها
ونستفيد من الامكانيات ليس فقط في اطار
التعاون القائم في ما بين القطاعين الخصين
وهذا تعاون مسمر لهما ومتسه ومصرف الصغير
الكثير من الشركات
الامريكيه ولكن ايضا هناك من الاليات لدى
الاداره
اذا موارد
تخفف
الحساب المصري
[موسيقى]
في اطار العلاقه الاستراتيجيه في علاقه
المتبادله لانه الاستقرار مصر وقوتها
ويسهل في
تحقيق المصالح المشتركه المصريه الامريكيه
واقف على الحرجه وبالتاكيد همم لدينا طموح
كبير وعلى شركائنا ان يلبوا هذا الطموح في
اطار العلاقه الاستراتيجيه في علاقه في
اطار المنفعه المتبادله وبانه استقرار مصر
وقوتها في همم تحقيق المصالح المشتركه
المصريه الامريكيه هو همم
[موسيقى]
هذه المصالح وما همم اتت به من عوائد
مباشره همم بالنسبه للجانبين
سؤال معالي وزير الخارجيه دلوقتي المتحده
قناه العربيه الاستاذ ناديه بلبيسي
الرئيس الوزراء في اجتماع وزاره
تحدث عن انتقام من الفلسطينيين ونزعل وسحب
الجنسيه منهم
بداوا بنصف بيوت الفلسطينيين هل هذا عقاب
جماعي هل فيه انتهاك للقوانين الدوليه
وحقوق الانسان
اتفضلي حضرتك تفضلي
اتفضلي حضرتك اقعدي
شكرا لك بدايه بسرعه حول السؤال الاخير
حول العلاقات
الاقتصاديه نعم لدينا تاريخ طويل من
العلاقات بين مصر
الولايات المتحده وتركيزنا الان على
تحديات الراهنه والفرص الراهنه التحديات
هي ان مصر كعدد من الدول
الصحفيه المشترك لوزير الخارجيه مصر
وامريكا سامح شكري
في العلاقات بين مصر والولايات المتحده
الاقتصادي والتجاري بين بلدينا ونسى عليه
كل الاطراف
تمثل اولويه لمصر ونعمل على مراعاه مصالح
القاهره وزير امريكا